starting
yes good morning
everyone time being
9:42 I'm going to open the work session
on
hp450 all right we have um four
amendments on
hp450 and
good morning my name is Keen Ming Wong
tax policy Council of the
Dr thank you Kean what I'd like U to
have you do is we have four amendments
before
us for for 450 we have
2272 H 2273 H 2274 H and
229h um if you could just go through
each of those briefly and tell us what
each one does that would be that'd be
believe um and I do
have
506 I think it's pretty much the same as
one of yours so um those those four the
the first three I mentioned were passed
2290 I thought went out in email what it
it's there there was a Dr well I'll let
I'll let ke explain what it is it's um
it's yeah right so um so the uh the
previous from in the from the previous
work session the discussions were on
H uh 2273 H and 2274 H so uh the
2272 H was amendments to line 7 through
9 and line
26 uh which is
yes representative yes the underlying
Bill removes the 80% so what does this
do differently uh no this is just um
remov to 80% and then it's on line 26 as
an additional um Amendment there to
apply that removal of the 80% to nonc
cor organizations as
well
yep representative Aly thank you on I'm
still not quite understanding
on there is added in a reference to to
a120 which
um is apparently what is referred to in
as adjust and adjusted which I don't
didn't understand why that was there at
all on and on
a120 is just say referring specifically
to the section that says that we are
2018 uh representative are you referring
to the 2272
H uh yeah wasn't that what you were just
talking about yes right so the the am
the amendment to line 26 is just to
encapsulate the uh to make sure that the
removal of the 80% does apply to the
well I didn't even see that in in
20 where does that show up in the
law that that they don't apply to the C
Corp to the nonse Corp the the federal
IRC uh 172 uh sorry the federal IRC uh n
deduction uh it is this IC 172 uh is
applicable to C Corps only and so uh
because in New Hampshire with all the
business organizations no matter C cor
or LLC or or what have you um so I
treated equally and the attempt on line
26 is just to make sure that it's clear
that this removal of the 80% cap as an
adjustment as opposed to a limited you
know so the original language here is uh
n as limited by the section so right now
the removal of 80% cap is not really a
limitation it's more of an adjustment so
that's why we thought that having this
language here would make it
clearer um and it's just to clarify that
that that it is in fact treated equally
across businesses somewhere in
A1 or somewhere in our code right the
the removal of the 80% cap is when it
says that U uh except in determining the
amount of the an deduction a business
organization shall not be subject to any
taxable income
limitation uh under the
172 right but I'm I'm asking about the
nonse
corpse where is that found in
our uh no so we we don't have that um so
but it's on the Federal Federal IRC
yeah oh well so I'll I take it for
granted that's that works I guess okay
all right continue all right uh so that
was uh two 2272
H so for Amendment 2273 H the amendment
was on line 14 which is the change in
the uh the limitation of the NL
carryover limited to 10 years extended
years representative Aly thank you so
we're about to switch a lot of the
people that are paying
BPT and we'll have a lot of new people
who are paying it who weren't paying or
some at least weren't paying it before
the way this is going to work is that
their
Federal um
Federal losses will be carried with them
to us from the past yes so um so this
that was the the discussion in the last
work session was with the change from
the 10 years to 20 years how about those
uh business organizations were just on
the border and then now it's being
extended 20 years so that's when uh this
is that's being addressed with the new
Amendment um
2290 h I I don't have a copy of that
Amendment I'm sorry we don't have yeah
you the only one with a copy we could
have this copy
um right so
2290 uh makes it clear that for taxable
periods ending on or after December 31st
2024 net operating losses can be carried
forward for 20 years so that implies
that previous to that those losses can
only go 10 years correct so that's
that's the change of this it was that
was a question I don't know if you
brought it up or somebody brought up
last time yeah what happens to those
people that are in the midst of a
10-year carry forward and suddenly it's
20 so so really
2273 obsolete in the sense or or it
clarifies 2273 so it's even if we
decided we wanted all these things 2290
is the clarification right of 20
okay okay and and so businesses that we
never taxed before but they're selling
into New
Hampshire um right now would be carrying
their their uh loss records from from
the federal government uh with them to
us and we abandon anything before
years when we're calculating
until we get 10 years out and everybody
is on the same
page um I'm I'm not getting that part
about that the business is that were
we're not taxing before are being taxed
now on the the single sales Factor okay
the businesses that didn't qualify
before but do qualify now we are told
that there at least going to be some of
them to replace the money losing from a
lot of other
places yes so for um for the the new
business organizations that will be
taxable in New Hampshire uh the the
2290h would the the amendments in 2290h
that says that uh NLS that uh that only
may be car for for 20 years uh for tax
will appear ending on or after December
31 2024 so any of the losses that's
generated Tex appearance ending on after
2024 would be subject to the 20-year
um Carry
forward but they'll bring their
histories with them yeah no yeah even
here
okay um Mr chairman yes you brought up a
point that you mentioned the word
obsolete for uh 73h is that or are you
saying that well it's it's not obsolete
but 2290 attempts to clarify
2273 thank
you representative plat yes Mr
Wong um are there any businesses who
have used the full 10 years for net
operating losss carry forward uh we we
tried to research on that um we are not
able to come up with uh with a
definitive answer uh this the the
collection of the data does not track
that
way
s uh Sarah um representative
ORS thank you Mr chair so uh thank you
for taking my question so do we have an
idea which businesses would impact New
Hampshire and what the dollar uh impact
might be uh we we do have an idea on the
dollar amounts but which businesses uh
to all all businesses are able to uh to
claim the netet uh n deductions so in
on so I'm referring to the uh the tax
expenditure report that uh the latest
sex expenditure report that was sent out
uh this was uh prepared in December of
22 uh every year the Dr prepares a tax
expenditure report uh and issues it in
in December time frame uh so the uh the
latest one that's out there is the
December 22 report and for fiscal year
22 uh the net operating
loss that the the tax that's decreased
by the usage of net operating loss was
274 so uh Amendment 2274 is an amendment
to remove the uh the $10 million cap on
the carry forwards as it's currently the
N deductions carry over uh limited to
$10 million uh so this amendment uh is
questions yeah represent Aly it's just
on I think I remember that that we have
no way of knowing how much loss we'd be
be
seeing that we'd have to pay for if um
if we do this yes that's correct uh we
um unfortunately we are not able to
information thank you Mr chairman yes Mr
Mr Wong uh then are you saying that it's
the federal amount that we would use
unlimited if this is
[Music]
removed that that is correct um so the
the taxpayers who are claiming net
operating losses they will be um if just
only this amendment uh they'll be
claiming whatever losses they can claim
in the any current year but then if they
have access losses they'll continue to
carry it over to the following year and
then um and then but that access carry
million okay um thank you I mean the the
intent here will be when we go into exec
session later we have these four ex we'
2290 all right thank
you I think we'd like to see um 2290
before we break for a
caucus okay let me
could
okay I'm going to close the work session
450 everything
here uh represent Aly you have a
question the next
one maybe I
should well may maybe I should wait
until you've opened this but if that's
what you're G to talk about yes yeah
okay we'll now open the work session on
HB
494 represent Aly thank you um
representative B Bixby is
uh on a three-day trip at this point
business trip uh
and we have been working um he has been
working especially with the agriculture
Department uh I think we have someone
here yes you uh and there have you got
the latest version of the amendment
which is
yesterday's Okay so so I would like to
go into the audience and uh also
talk um what about this but um the
situation is that we have an amendment
which he sent in draft form but it was a
little too drafty uh to on OSS and asked
them to get it out by yesterday and they
did and he looked at it as he was
leaving and and uh rewrote it um
fortunately just before he left uh and
sent it back to them to redraft and I
have what he sent which I read and it
looks pretty much like what we all had
agreed to do on we discussed this also
in dedicated funds yesterday the chair
and I were both are both on that
committee um on
and
on there's a certain amount of mess
involved in this part of the
departmental structure and this cleans
it up better than if we tried to do it
through dedicated funds and it is the
same subject the for everybody else the
the problem is that uh representative
Bixby was interested in having uh more
fertilizer and lming and other testing
done because there's almost nothing so
the consumers both um of nurseries and
of of um on for agricultural purposes
have no guarantee that the products
being sold in this state are what they
say they are um which is a kind of a
central function under the Department of
Agriculture and so he put in a bill that
creates a new dedicated fund just to do
that the trouble is there is another
dedicated fund with too much money in it
at the moment which um does
that which is supposed to do that and
which in the compendium of dedicated
funds the department states that we all
think that we ought to be doing a lot
more with fertilizing and liing and that
kind of stuff testing so
um we've been working to replace the
bill
with making sure that that is actually
done inside of the dedicated fund it's
supposed to be done in and uh and
revising that dedicated fund so that it
doing so uh that's what this is I would
like to be able to pull it out and maybe
you can talk while I'm doing
that director can you introduce
yourself my name is Alan Wyman with the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food I am the division director of
regulatory services and responsible for
the oversight of these programs we're
discussing here associated with this
bill I think representative alamy stated
it fairly clearly um there's not much
more I can add other than to say that
some of these
rules and reg well the regulations and
rules preate
1985 over time things have gotten
somewhat squirly as a director I'm
trying to figure out you know what uh
I'm trying to make sure the money could
be tracked as it should be and this
helps to clean up everything I I um the
purpose of moving these closing these
dedicated funds putting in a separate
Simplicity and and tracking better
better use of the fund actually better
use of the funds for the purpose for
which they were they are being um uh
gathered
so so does this proposed amendment
create a new dedicated
fund no what we're trying to do here is
is put it into a an a pre-existing
dedicated fund but that pre-existing
dedicated fund has a name that doesn't
really match the purpose of the fund I
don't know how that long ago that
happened or why but it's time to to
clean it up and make sure that that the
funding is going into the correct
dedicated fund with the correct name for
the correct purposes uh I mean it's all
working that way now but it's so
scattered that it's not clear this this
represent I I don't see the name of the
old fund so it's clear that the new name
is replacing the old fund's name that is
that is correct how do I know that's not
creating another fund uh BEC BEC it's
intended to replace the old fund with a
different name name so this this this is
going
to um it's going to what we currently
call the scale testing fund
the scale testing fund has nothing to do
with scale testing it has to do with
product registration which is what this
this money is for uh the purpose of the
money gathered that's being moved to the
scale testing fund is for product
registration inspection sampling
um so in the process of trying to clean
things up we also thought it made sense
to to correct and there's another bill
that will correct the or I say correct
but change the scale testing fund to
product rist ation
um so that's more reflective of of what
is actually those funds are are are
being used
for follow up it yes 43520 I should look
it up with now but that refers to a
scale testing fund so with the amend
43520 it now says agricultural products
regulatory fund it will be clear that
the new name is the same fund with a
different name I hope so that's the
point and that's the purpose um you know
through the legislative process and
however this manages to flow through
that process at the end of the day we're
going to have one fund product
registration fund used to be called the
scale testing fund um and this money is
going there all this should not be
creating any additional funds it should
funds I don't you know relative to the
legislative process and how those name
changes occur I I don't understand
that what is what do why that's why I
asked the question what is preventing us
from um I think representative Aly
mentioned that um the current
fund is supposed to do product testing
what is what is stopping us from doing
product
testing so I I came into the division
approximately two years ago now when I
got in uh I noted as I think everybody
already understood that a lot of this
testing hadn't been done for quite some
time and from my perspective looking in
uh being fairly new to this position
what I saw was an extraordinar amount of
time being taken up in in in two aspects
the organic program takes a significant
amount of staff time I don't think years
ago that was the case but the program
has
exploded um and feed and fertilizer uh
registrations where I have two people
who sit for months in putting in
information into a database which they
should be out there doing sampling and
inspection so simultaneous to this we
also have talks going on to butress off
the animal industry's database to try to
create a database in which those two
people could spend significantly less
time at a desk in putting information
and going out and doing sampling and so
forth so it's it's a we're we're trying
to process things in a way that creates
significantly greater efficiencies in
the division using taxpayers dollars you
know um and I just don't
from again from my perspective coming in
from the private sector these were
inefficiencies I saw immediately that
probably have been in place for well
they've been in place for decades so
it's it's sort of like let's clean
things up let's get things efficient
let's bring budgets into accounts where
they truly belong call them what they
truly do and and that just makes life
easier certainly for me and it allows us
to to focus um our our Personnel where
they
belong
representa
Aly
you thank you on I promised
representative Bixby that I'd speak
about the bill on the this is the way he
he did it he did not take the time that
the drafter is taking now to um modify
the existing language he just
removed uh the words product testing and
product and scale testing uh it has a
variety of names of that sort uh
throughout and it the purposes of the
fund are not uh explained except by the
title in the rsas right
now on but the it is within the
agricultural
uh part of the rsas and it was always
meant to be dealing with testing of
agricultural products which included
udes the livestock agricult in
agriculture uh and that is why part of
the money is coming
from dog
licenses um because they are also
supposed to be testing dog food products
and I think that's also not going
on on and the scale part of it nobody
can figure out as he said but where that
came from but it hasn't been done in the
memory of anybody that's in agriculture
at this point so um what the existing
language says on which will will be
are now
in uh now coming into that
fund and the other two four uh 4314 and
six
are pretty
small about
$300,000 a year I think on that will be
added into it to help pay for the
fertilizer the other problem with this
fund is that
it has over
a um endof year balance of over a
million dollars that is always there and
their revenues and their expenses pretty
much equal each other but that is before
they do the fertilizer testing and a lot
of what it's doing is paying for on the
20th
century um
data uh early 20th iny data collection
and um and
registration rather than computerization
they are now trying to spread
computerization of all of their
registration um around the department
into databases but they're start they've
been starting with the animal products
one that the um the commissioner got
through last
year
uh which is just starting to be built so
we're in the early stages of coming into
the 21st century in the agriculture
Department uh so it also says which will
shall be credited to
the
uh Agricultural and scale testing I
can't remember exactly what
Horticultural and scale testing I don't
know where the Horticultural part came
from
but uh except that it's part of
Agriculture uh and it will be credited
to the that the Agriculture and scale
testing fund and the drafter will x that
out and put in in bold the agricultureal
products regulatory fund which a after a
fair amount of discussion inside of the
department they decided was the best way
to call this because it's what they
really meant it to be
doing or what they think they've really
meant it to be doing for quite some time
now so um that's uh that goes throughout
here and most of this is just on
renaming this
fund on getting it straight in the 612
set ction which is U the dedicated funds
and adding those two
small um oh an
adding
purpose which is is on the back there
the purpose of the fund uh in the second
to last paragraph is the first time that
the purpose of the fund is being put
into the law which would be very helpful
I think for the future
uh and uh when he he says uh including
the inspection sampling and testing of
commercial feed parenthesis
43519 that's going to come back from the
drafter as something
um
and and most of the rest of it is
changing
the name of
it and uh establishing the linkage with
612 but it does it does what
representative Bixby and the uh
agriculture committee which passed this
over to us uh wanted to
do uh in that fund is to return it to
the purpose that they thought it had had
for quite some time and and start the
process of of
uh creating the databases that they need
in this area as well as as a few other
areas I think under your your section so
that the agriculture staff can do what
they were supposed to be doing which is
out in the
field okay now excuse me uring plants so
yesterday we we learned that uh was it
250,000 that was in the budget for the
database um does that um does that not
free up people
director you want or do you want me to
do that it's that do you think that's a
more legislative or well I could tell
you that the
250,000 uh is uh more specific to I
think the animal industry's database and
in their division
um we have also the weights and measures
which is in desperate need desperate
need more probably than anybody uh my
division also needs a database structure
and uh Pier's group uh planted the trees
as well um we're still working with uh
pesticides to figure out what their
needs are but that 250 is is for
specific to the standing up a DayDay
base for animal
industry okay so this I'll get you in a
minute um so this the original bill
created a new dedicated fund correct so
now this amendment which is it'll
replace all replaces the replace all so
now we're no longer creating a new
dedicated fund we are
redefining changing changing the title
of the current dedicated fund and also
being specific on what the dedicated
doing okay representative PL will we get
the amendment in time to handle L
today I have Karen trying to work on
that but I think he probably sent it to
him about the same time he sent this to
me which was around 5:00 yesterday
so I'm not sure whether we could do it
today or not but the other thing is I
think this needs a um public
hearing so it would have to be done with
the next meeting whenever we're going to
be able to do that which I think is also
a
problem but we have until the 17th of
November for
these except that the chair's go leaving
for a
while
um director Allen I guess if this
um if this was not passed what what is
because we have uh right right now if if
if if these funds are transferred over
to what will be called the product
regulatory um we'll we'll have Equity
between input and output uh the fees
coming in in in and the cost going out
we
have so theoretically it would be
problematic into the next budgetary
cycle but we have a buffer here in this
in this budget um that we're hoping to
put towards the it upgrades uh so I
don't know which which are in process
and are going to take time so if it
doesn't pass this cycle is it going to
be a huge deal I I don't think so um but
that's that's the situation we're in
we're we're Equity right now between
what's coming in what's coming out uh we
have a bit of a buffer we're hoping that
buffer can be used towards the it
upgrades uh for freeing up staff to do
what they're supposed to be
doing what is your what is your buffer
right now it was
1.7 million was it I one and a half give
or take yes um yeah I think that
250,000 is coming out of you know and
I'm not yeah it's coming out of that so
so it's going to be probably less than
1.5 somewhere 1.45 something of that H
once the 250 comes
out okay representative Aly if I could
answer that only I think that the major
implication would be that for another
two years we're not going to um they
won't be
testing
fertilizer uh dog
food on all the other animal food
products as well and and they will be
mostly sitting at their desks inputting
data when they could be starting to move
out into the field and act acting like a
Department of
Agriculture representative
bames I just wanted to say first it
looks like uh some hard work has been
done here and it's just straightening
things out basically this that's that's
what we're talking about and um if it
takes a public hearing I guess because
it's not in Germain is not the idea um
so be it we we've got uh where are we
we're mid October now we've got till mid
no November we should be able to manage
done representative ORS uh thank you Mr
chair so uh thanks for taking my
question would you be able to move a
clerical position into inputting in the
database and let these people get out to
the field I figure they're certified
or they're trained to do the testing
that's a great question so we do have a
data Clerk and when this program started
my only guess is because I wasn't around
when it was started but from the
information I see in the data I've
witnessed historically
this program has exploded so now it's
it's taking our our data Clerk and our
inspector to do that work um it it's a
lot under the division just things have
yes representative Lee
Lee thank you um I just want to thank
the director for all of the work that I
think it would be very daunting to walk
into a job and be like oh this hasn't
been updated for 30 years so I just want
to say thank you um I think that our
citizens expect that the state is doing
this work and I want to thank you for
for bringing to our attention mention
that it that it's not and sounds like
funds are
appropriated um just bureaucracy and
time has gotten in the way so I really
appreciate you bringing this to us and I
hope that we won't slow this down but um
speed it up and get this work done
because I know for me if you if we bring
this back in a year I'm going to be like
what and so I know for myself I would
have to redo a lot of the mental work to
understand so I hope that we can T can
get this done and serve the people in
the way that we're supposed to so thank
you so much for all of the extra work to
to call attention to this and bring it
you
306 I'll close the um public hearing on
HP 494 um not public hearing we'll close
that's what you wanted had unfortunately
it we're just going to wait uh a minute
to get um representative Jordan down
Eller
all right
um I'm going to open the work session on
S SP
112 and Senator Lang you have um a
proposed
amendment thank you Mr chair thank you
members of the committee I'm passing
around an amendment that I draft
although it's a senate Amendment if you
guys choose to go forward with it you'd
have to have it redrafted as a house
amendment to adopt it um the amendment
goes back to our favorite conversation
point of historic horse raising and
moratoriums um so I I've been working
with various um individuals and entities
to try to get to a place where we can
all come to an agreement whether that be
in the executive branch as well as the
um uh representative have wanted to uh
have everyone receive sure I'll
wait
you
okay all right so TR again so the bill
before you again I work with the lottery
the governor's office as well as members
of my own Committee in the Senate um to
get to a point where there would be
something that we could potentially move
forward that would get a signature at
the end of the day and we'd be able to
uh move forward with a moratorium um as
you remember the governor's veto message
was the conversation around free market
and the fact that there has to be some
free market growth um in the industry
that was a significant portion of his of
his veto message to the legislature um
what this bill does is it allows for
some incremental growth what the
amendment does it allows for some
incremental growth so if if um a gaming
op a gaming gaming operator employer um
it who put an application in between
January 1 and October 15th and the
October 15th date is because I didn't
want to rush to lottery for a gaming
operations so I made sure it was a date
before this committee was going to act
and before the amendment was made public
so that there wasn't a rush on lottery
for uh applications but I think we've
all recognized that a store course
racing has had an impact in the
Hampshire on our charitable gaming
operations and what this bill will do is
allow some incremental growth so anybody
who's who invested money and put in for
a gaming operators license in the
anticipation of the 2024 expiration date
was going to happen um it would allow
them to be able to continue to move
forward if they've filed an application
with Lottery between January 1st of this
year and October 15th of this year um
those people had a reasonable
expectation to think that they would be
eligible for historic horse racing
license June uh July 1 as of this year
of of 24 so uh what I've done is I've
allowed for some incremental growth you
can I think director McIntyre's room you
can talk to him how many applicants that
are I have no idea I just wanted to
allow for some incremental growth to
occur and the second thing this
amendment does is it extends the
moratorium out for four years um as you
all know we have a a gaming commission
that's meeting that doesn't have a
report due to the end of next year um
this will allow time for that commission
to do its work to see what the impact of
histor course racing is on the industry
and whether or not um it should be
adjusted and then gives time for the
legislative process that needs to occur
after that report's been filed so the
legislature can consume that report and
figure out what bills because it's it's
due in December it's passed all the
filing deadlines so we'd have to wait a
whole another nine months before you
potentially would see a bill um after
the committee report and hence the
reason why I pushed the moratorium out
four years to give all of that process
time allowed to happen um again this is
this was done in cooperation with the
governor's office my committee and ways
and means in the Senate um and the
Lottery Commission I'm proposing it to
the house as a reasonable compromise to
be able to to put some uh constraints on
HHR until we have a report but also
allow some incremental growth in the
industry um in light of the governor's
free market argument and I'm happy to
questions representative ducet thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question you've referenced twice working
with the governor's office are you are
you telling me that the governor's
office wants this piece of legislation
I'm kind of confused as to the message
there again with the incremental growth
as my my understanding that it would
receive a
signature could you repeat that sure
with the incremental growth my
understanding will get the signature it
alleviates the governor's original
response to the legislature about the
free market allows the free market to
continue um without opening the doors
Forever Until We have that report from
the from the gaming commission follow up
follow up so I I remember you testifying
in front of this committee about s SP51
and how you work with the governor's
office and that was going to get a
signature how how can we be assured that
this is going to get a sign I was a
surprised as surprised as you were
represented I don't want to be surprised
again okay again I can only tell you
that I worked with the lottery office
and the governor's office to try to find
a compromise to be able to move
something forward because I I in
addition to you agree that a rampant
expansion of HHR could potentially cause
a problem but I'm a guy who works on
data we don't have any data we have
feelings right now and I don't work a
lot on feelings we think it's going to
we know we but we don't know the whole
point of the commission is to get to we
know and so this bill will allow an an
expansion of the moratorium until we can
get to a we know and when we know we can
then act on legislation but until then
again it's I think I feel I it might and
I'd rather have facts and data which is
exactly what the commission is supposed
to do so we extend the moratorium with
some incremental growth until we can get
that data from um from from the
commission and then we can act on on
proper legislation
further represent PL I may be showing my
ignorance here but what does historic
horse racing got to do with charitable
gaming sure thank you so historic horse
racing is a loud component of charitable
gaming in our charitable Gaming
facilities um it has a revenue split
just like table games do with Charities
and everybody else so a certain portion
of all the revenue that comes in is
distributed between the state Charities
Ames yeah I I basically have two
questions I'll merge them um the first
is what you you think about the question
of germanness and the need for having a
hearing on this amendment um and uh it's
it's consistent with our discuss
discussion of a bill we just were
talking about it's you know that was um
maybe arguable this may be a little less
arguable in terms of it's a subject that
was a part of the large issue of these
gambling undertakings that uh it was
definitely not in 112 the uh
moratorium um as I recall so my
understanding is 112 was s in the r
shardis Bill did have the moratorium in
it this is just a different
implementation of that section of that
bill okay I didn't I missed that we can
go back to that my understanding is that
was the case no problem uh if it's not
the case then it's not a real problem we
can we can have a hearing um and the
second thing is I I strongly support the
the uh need for an extension of the mor
moratorium and I I thank you for pushing
that too and uh and the idea of folding
in trying to be fair so that the
Enterprises that
have worked to uh to start a process and
invested money would not be cut out by
this moratorium I think that's the idea
um but um four years seems like a lot of
time and uh to me it's more time than
it's needed uh I'd be comfortable with
two years and maybe you could
uh you could talk about the why why4 and
not two because maybe there's a good
reason um I'm completely open but but my
bias is not to make it too long because
this is this is essentially enabling
monopolies to develop and to um capture
the ground so to speak uh before anybody
else can get in thank you thank you for
your question so again I obviously
accept two years my my thought was along
the legislative process process again
the committee report from the charitable
G from the charitable gaming commission
isn't du out until December of 24 um
filing dates gone right so that means 25
is a dead year you wouldn't be able to
pass any legislation in 25 which means
the first time you have the opportunity
to submit legislation September of 25 to
be heard in 26 and by that time the
moratorium would end within six months
if we didn't take action so so my my
plan was the idea was to give it a
little longer time for the legislative
process to occur given the dates of the
commission report our filing periods and
all of that um while I wouldn't oppose
the two-year again that was a senate
position originally when we brought the
bill forward and that was passed
originally um I just in looking back at
the at the legislative process I
realized that we have no time to file a
bill in 25 um so that was
all uh if I may uh yes follow up just
responding to that uh it seems to me the
commission you and I are both on this
commission and will'll work hard and uh
um we could get the job done in October
and if uh Bill needed was needed and I I
expect there will be a bill that's
needed I think we'll all want to uh have
it processed worked on in the following
calendar year which means uh getting it
in within the deadline whatever the
deadline is I don't know in the second
year what the deadline usually is for uh
uh filing bills uh it's a little later
than it is this year so right again so
we' be in the first year of a new
election cycle right the November of 24
is going to have the election cycle mean
all you'd have a window in November for
filing bills but then it's gone when
you're elected right you have a window
of time and the committee reports not do
out till December 1st which is past
filing deadlines and so that potentially
you could do a late Bill filing but then
that's up to the subject of somebody
else so um that was my concern was
strictly Bill filing periods running
through the election cycle and when
you're allowed to file bills so again if
you want to modify down to two year
three years right to give that whole
session uh whole term next term U the
the 24 and 25 um or 26 and 27 term I'd
be fine with that as
well representative shamberg you had a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh along the same
lines that representative Ames brought
up that if moratorium is mentioned in
here there's no need for a public
hearing per se but wasn't Senate Bill
112 doesn't wasn't it dealing with
breakage and those items and that's
would be non- gerain with this
particular bill here again I think it
had lots of components to it there were
lots of stuff that was in there
including breakage which was part of it
um so again my understanding if I
remember right 112 did include a
moratorium provision if it did then it
leaves moratorium as a as a I may be
wrong I I'm pretty sure I'm right and
that's why 112 was suggested as the
vehicle um to be able to move this
forward representative
Aly thank you just first I don't see the
moratorium in the bill but um I haven't
read every word right now um but on I
wanted to ask
what is really moving towards a
monopolized situation right now is that
um The Lottery Commission despite
something that was in the original bill
that said that once a owner has a
license it cannot be transferred has
found a way that it is
transferred um my um not yet built
casino is part of a four group group
casino that was on that was uh put
together by uh diagnosed in Manchester
he has now sold it to somebody
else uh and who is in the the business
nationally and and this seems to be
going on a fair amount that these
licenses are being transferred in a way
that I don't not
being in that area of law I don't really
understand but on this seems to me to be
a more immediate concern
than new people get as part of getting
into the
business what what specifically again I
don't I don't necessarily disagree with
your representative Aly at all um
however I had a conversation
representative AMS and I think the
problem is that that's that if I did I
originally had language to put in here
about ownership and 50% ownership and
transfer of licensers and that kind of
thing however it would be non- gerain at
that point because now we're talking
about the overall issue of a gaming
license where this is talking
specifically about historic horse racing
so I think would have been non- gerain
so um I think there you you'll be
hearing about that in the upcoming
session if I if I'm not
mistaken representative ducet did you
have a
question yeah my recollection of uh s
sp12 it does have to break its language
and I I have a proposed amendment that
I'm reading through that I submitted to
OLS that doesn't address it I believe
Lottery and and we can ask them had an
issue with a specific uh component
relative to the
language uh breakage in relation to
HHR and that that needed some kind of
housekeeping cleanup there so I don't
know if attorney formella can answer
that but I believe that's the connection
it should be in my Amendment and it's
not
also okay
attorney my
apologies uh legal counsel for the
lottery I'm sorry okay is legal council
me um the question is we're trying to
figure out if this is in sb12 it's it's
my understanding there was some
confusion with the breakage language in
relation to HHR can you clear that up
for us because I I thought I had
submitted in my proposal to OSS for my
Amendment it doesn't seem to be in
Senator Langs either and there was
something he wanted cleaned up there and
that's that's with the link with these
amendments come
from okay I'll I'll dig it up thank you
Mr
chair any other
lley um like representative PL I'm
afraid that my question may reveal my
ignorance
um but it's kind of along the same lines
um so there's been a lot of articles in
the newspaper lately about charitable
gaming and how it works and how much
money is being generated and I had this
number in my head about 24% right we
charitable gaming generated more 24%
more gross I think just gross um over
the last year so this is really a big
big big number that we're talking about
and I was talking to a constituent and
she was like and and this may be mixing
two things together and that's part of
why I'm asking the question so you can
separate them out because I'm sure
constituents are right are watching at
home we're talking about breakage and
it's all getting very um detailed right
um but she said I don't understand we
have the Lottery Commission it's
supposed to be funding our schools you
know more and more people are gambling
every year what where is all the money
that's supposed to be you know funding
our schools and I'm looking at this
newspaper article um that talks about
the 24% increase in charitable gaming
and it says
um donations to charitable gaming uh to
charitable organizations are made on a
you know rotating cycle it's trying to
explain throughout the period 35% of the
gross revenues from games of chance will
be donated to charitable organizations
and then in the next line it says in
historical horse racing when players use
the machines to place bets The Gaming
facilities keep 12% % of the money it
makes after giving out prizes while it
may appear that casinos are D donating
more to Charities only 3% of gross
revenues is split between Charities and
the New Hampshire Lottery Commission so
it it does seem to go to representative
pl's question of like what does historic
horse racing have to do with charitable
gaming and if I understand the article
correctly it's it's very different how
much money is going to whereare
according to this article 3% is split
between the Charities and the
fund can you walk me through and help me
answer my my constituent's question I
can and I think director McIntyre behind
me will also do a good job at answering
this question but so understand that
games of chance table games blackjack
poker those kind of things there's a
thing called ggr which is gross Gaming
revenue gross Gaming revenue is the
amount of money left over after we've
paid all the players their winnings
right and that's basically your profit
right for lack of a better phrase that's
your profit your profit Line in games of
chance that split up um with the charity
uh getting 35% in table games so Poker
Black Jack when you play that charity
gets a larger percentage in historic
Horse Rising The Operators take 12% off
the top of of the handle the total
amount raised that 12% is then split up
between the state the charity
and the gaming operator with the state
and charity taking 25% and the gaming
75% but Charlie will correct me if I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure I'm right on
that yes you shakeing his head yes yeah
I'm
right so to answer your question
historic racing gets a lesser percentage
than than table games um and so um and
but but we've already exceeded our
Revenue projections for HHR than more
than we ever thought we were going to
get so Charities will be seeing money
from that which is a new Revenue stream
for lack of a better phrase for the
Charities because we didn't have HHR
before but the question is and the
question the committee is going to
struggle with the gaming commission is
is the increased Revenue that's being
done on HHR is that having an impact on
table games where the Charities get a
significant higher portion and we don't
know the answer to that yet that's the
whole point of the commission is to dig
into that and understand are we
cannibalizing and giving Charities less
money because we' we've implemented the
new gaming structure I don't know the
answer to that that's the reason why we
have the commission is I don't know
whether or not we're can HHR is
cannibalizing table games which is going
to result in less revenues for Charities
we won't know that until we get some
data and we don't have that yet can I
have a followup followup so
the HHR is not there's no rent for
example the you're just getting that 3%
is just getting
divided I don't know where you're
getting a 3% from again it's 12% well so
yeah 75% uh 25% which is split between
the state and the charity would be 3% of
12% so yes I get understand why you got
the 3% number now um so yes that the
um I don't believe there's rent again
there I think again Charlie might be
able to answer that question but I don't
believe there's rent on HHR there is
rent on table games so GES a chance
35% that goes to the Charities um some
of that is taken up in rent correct so
they pay part of that money back to the
casino owner in rent correct so it could
be 20% it could be 15% it could be 5%
that the charity walks away with so it's
a fixed number um again we we talked
about this in the gaming commission it
is a if you remember the bill we pass
passed that established the CH gaming
commission there were five charges of
the commission and one of them was to
talk about rent to specifically look at
the rent issue is is pulling back money
from Charities after you've done after
you've done the money and whether or not
that that's a reasonable practice or not
okay um so that is an explicit charge
within the charitable gaming commission
helpful yes thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question so if it's
only 12% and they're splitting
7525 why don't we change the numbers so
if it is pirating from the other games a
chance that the Charities won't be
taking a big loss can this be done well
again that is one of the charges of this
commission is to look at the the split
if you will what that looks like and how
that works so again we don't have data
yet right but we we have there's only
seven locations that have been active in
historic Horse Rising and even of some
of those they've been active less than a
year right so we still have to collect
dat data to try to see what that looks
like so there may be a split change
there may not be we don't know CU we
haven't seen the data yet the whole
point of this is not to let the thing
explode before we've got the data and
can see what the impact was and so hence
the reason for a request for a
moratorium okay follow up so do we have
uh even a small amount of data that we
could possibly collect like six months
or whatever and get an idea maybe what's
happening or well again that's the goal
of the commission right we'll have a a
full year worth of data or that we
should be able to look at um but again
we're working a little bit in the blind
because the annual reports you know when
they're done and what what it looks like
again director McIntyre could probably
answer a lot of these questions but we
have some data but we don't have a full
impact because we're still in the ramp
phase right we're still ramping up so
the numbers you know it's hard to pick
look at the numbers when you have a
October number that's low and a November
number that's high because two more
places went online right and what the
and we don't know what the charity split
will look like long term and so again
and the whole point of the commission
and giving an extended commission to the
end of next year was be able to collect
you thank you Mr chairman uh I'm going
to join my colleagues representative and
representative leapley in uh feeling as
though I'm putting my ignorance on
display this this seems to be the day
for it um I am sometimes although
sometimes I feel as though I'm getting a
better handle on the charitable gaming
piece of the gaming stuff um most times
I feel like the more I hear the less I
understand I would like to
request uh a not not today to do not to
do this today but to give get a
presentation about how all of this works
that would
include how decisions get made about
which Charities are selected I don't
understand that there is any consistent
process uh how much the Charities have
uh it would help me to get an idea of
what we are actually looking at and I I
have have to reiterate I am more
confused today than I was yesterday
thank you Mr chair so I there was a
presentation done to the gaming
commission this week and I can get that
presentation it has the breakdown of
financials and a basic basic
understanding of all gaming in New
Hampshire whether it's Lottery lucky s
Bingo it has a breakdown of that and the
commission the director is also going to
get us a primer a basic primer on
language and what what it means when
you're talking about CH what is a handle
mean what does ggr mean what do these
phrases mean um and I'm sure we can
share that with the Ways and Means
Committee
yeah that sounds like a good idea
followup thank you Mr chairman I would
also really like to understand how
Charities are chosen um I
don't what I the last I understood and
again I don't know if this is accurate
or not is that each uh Casino gets
requests from uh charities in the area
and they choose which Charities they are
going to give their funds to
um if this money is in
effect money that is taken away is
segregated from money that could
potentially be going to education and to
the business
owners I think it makes sense for us to
take a look at whether that's the best
way to do that and to try to make sure
that there aren't say favored Charities
of a particular particular casino owner
and that charity consistently gets funds
and others
don't so again Mr CHL remind you that is
exactly that is a significant issue and
it's why it's one of the five charges
again rent being one of them how
Charities are selected as a second
charge in that commission that we're
looking at how that happens and whether
that should be regulated um so you're
not alone in your concerns about how
Charities are picked and I will tell you
that is part of the commission's
responsibility is to look at that and
um any other questions I think at this
at this time um we are going to need we
already talked about the possible need
of a public hearing I know
representative ducet has a um amendment
that uh may need a public hearing as
well so what I would say is hold
questions regarding this because during
that we're going to have a public
hearing and I would also ask Lottery
once we know what that date is to to
come in and answer some of these
additional questions so we can uh move
on at this time before we move on will
Lottery be speaking today on this
particular
Amendment uh if not I do have some
questions for lottery if they would
wouldn't mind coming up just real
quick
quick I was going to suggest this is not
an amendment that's been submitted by
any of the members of this committee I
have one that will be and I spe laud
will speak to it and it's suspiciously
similar in text with some changes so I
think it would cover what you getting
that there representative Mr Mr chair my
particular
particular questions about who is
involved how many and where these people
that have put applications in are
located I thought maybe the director
could
answer that I don't know if that would
well that sounds like it it may uh also
be similar to representative El Berger's
question about who are the Charities how
are they chosen it's not the Charities
I'm sorry it's the applicants that want
to do this uh file for license new
licenses all right so okay uh director
could you come forward and answer that
applicants
uh good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm Charlie McIntyre
Lottery director and with me is our
chief compliance officer John conord um
that was actually several questions
representative shamberg so which one let
me just if I may just repeat them sure
how many applicants are in the queue
right now uh between January 1st and
October 15 currently there will be four
four second question uh uh do you have a
public list of who they are no under the
terms of the HHR law as passed and
signed in the law applications are
confidential so I'm not allowed to
discuss it okay and well third question
since you can't give their names can you
identify where they are located these
individuals that have applied what state
they may be from or anything like that I
cannot all the terms of the application
are considered confidential so I can't
thank you Mr
chairman thank you that's it all right
amendment thank you Mr
chairman uh not to
belor any further the you'll note that
some of the language here is uh
relatively the same and I'll wait for
the amendment to go around as the piece
you just
got
and and if I might add Mr chair while
people are getting the amendment the
members are getting the amendment we're
talking about a singular game here HHR
these charitable gaming houses have in
numerous games Blackjack roulette poker
21 we could go on and on with different
choices we talking about a very specific
game an electronic game that this
legislature went back and forth over
about six years okay and I I was a
proponent a great proponent and still
remain a great proponent for this
because what it did in fact was these
charitable Gaming facilities that host
the ability to have HHR in their
facilities serve two Charities a day
instead of one at the end of the day
that's what this is about it's about
charitable
gaming so to me at least the argument
about free market and I'm a free market
guy this does not negate anybody's
ability to apply with lottery for a
charitable gaming license and be
approved and open a facility with local
approval and open a charitable gaming
license and I guess I'd ask uh director
McIntyre back because I do have a direct
question in in relation to
this what what we did as a legislature
in in bringing forward HHR was to offer
that added component and obviously the
component right
now and I would venture to say that we
have just scratched the surface as to
the impact of this one particular game
in these gaming halls and I guess my
question for the director is prior to
the approval and the uh signing at the
law of HHR how many charal gaming
license had you received let's just say
in the prior five
years um good morning and thank you for
taking my question I'm sorry the
question I'm have Chief compliance
officer answer so representative you
said this would be an estimate by would
say over the past five years we probably
have received in the neighborhood of
eight to 10 applications prior to the
HHR prior to HHR okay and subsequent to
the and that's over how many five years
over five years okay so roughly eight I
would say eight to 10 again there would
be an estimate there's probably some
leeway in there okay and since January 1
with the Advent and the ability for
people to apply for HHR licenses coupled
with charitable gaming is is there a way
to break that out or let me let me step
back here how many charitable game
gaming license applications have you
received at Lottery since January 1
since January 1 for games of chance uh
as director maryre said we currently
have four okay four four cents in the
last few months less than a year in the
last year or so yes okay okay and and if
I could ask another question how many of
The
Operators that held charitable gaming
licenses prior to HHR have changed
hands if I if I could the technically
there was no changing of hands the
corporation which was licensed
previously is still the licensed
Corporation the shares of that
Corporation were sold so essentially the
same LC e exists it's just um the shares
are held by different owners okay so no
none have changed hands correct and that
was an opinion by the Attorney General's
office notk thank you for that so what
I'm getting at with this amendment this
this covers uh a lot of uh house clean
keeping issues uh unruly patrons and
such but to the Crux of this again we're
at the moratorium and and I I restate
we're talking about one component one
game
HHR terrible gaming I'm I'm also a
member of the uh gaming commission but
I'm also a member of this legislature
and and a commission does not negate us
legislating what we need to legislate to
deliver for our
constituency it's not the the first time
you've heard me say and I I will take I
have broad shoulders I I was a very big
proponent for HHR but but even I
wouldn't have expected to see what we've
seen in the growth of these particular
games I live in the town of Salem
anybody lives on a Border Town Nashua
seab Brook Salem and the like can
understand the interest for some outside
uh interests to come in and and start
charal gaming Halls because that's the
model we have here in New Hampshire and
by the way in within the borders of New
Hampshire I think we have
14 terrible Gaming facilities if I'm
correct uh operating that is correct
okay at present we have 14 four in the
queue with applications with Lottery
that that's the possibility of some 18
Which is far in excess of anything in
the totality of New England so to say
that a moratorium on a singular
game is negative to the free market I I
I don't agree with that argument quite
frankly and and if we look at it this
way I I sat on the gaming commission on
Tuesday and I heard uh the dean of the
Senate Senator L alesandro speak about
how much of the airwaves and especially
the news media coverage of Simply
DraftKings is taking on and I don't know
in case you not notice but there are
many vendors for sports gaming but for
some reason we have one vendor in the
state of New Hampshire
that's a monopoly okay this isn't about
monopolies this isn't about negating the
ability of anybody to take on the
ability to open a chable gaming Hall and
to help those
communities that uh would welcome charal
gaming and and reap the benefits from
the revenue for the Charities so in this
I offer up the ability and I had this
drafted well before and if you look on
line
19 I put a drop dead date of September
1 and with uh conversations with Lottery
it's come to my attention that a more
appropriate date would be October 18th
which was yesterday so it would cover
the four applicants at present that are
in the queue but it would be my position
and I understand the position of of uh
of others on on this Committee
in that uh two years or four years maybe
I think you know the days of kicking the
can down the road on issues we need to
address upfront and and full boore are
are here so I'm I'm a little animated
about this because I I bear some of the
responsibility of getting this passed
and I don't want the state of New
Hampshire to turn into the state of New
Jersey and I don't want Salem New
Hampshire to become Atlantic
City okay also if you note in the last
uh section of my Amendment it eliminates
the rent component hard stop no rent it
should have been gone a long time ago
so uh I I know that we should and we
will in discussions with the clerk uh
we're going to have to have a work
session on this and we can talk at this
at length but I I think my position is
very clear to see on this um
and um I look forward to having those
discussions so thank
you thank you uh representative elberger
thank you uh Mr chairman I I want to
make clear I want to clarify what I
think I heard because if I got it right
it makes no sense to me in nashwa we
currently have two small casinos that
were owned by a nashille resident
who as I understood it sold the license
to an outof State group that is going to
be closing those two casinos and moving
them into the old Sears building in the
Pheasant Lane Mall which is not just a
border City I mean the parking lot is in
Massachusetts and the the building is in
New
Hampshire I think what you said was that
that license wasn't really sold I'm I'm
trying to get my head around this one
too
I I can only suggest to you that gaming
can I move this yes please thank
you uh I can only suggest you that
gaming operators are amongst the most
single most talented people at finding
loopholes I would point you to Missouri
where there are only Riverbats and the
law allows you to be overwater so as
long as you're over water at some point
it's the riverbat even though you go
down 12 levels and there's a puddle in
the basement um the license was not sold
the shares of the company were sold and
with that went the assets of the company
and that included the ability to apply
for and receive a license for HHR this
was what as was explained to us the
Attorney General's office so pined on
this and approved it it was not our
idea thank you my my hair which is
already thin feels like it's getting
farther
representative
Boger thank you Mr chairman
um in looking at the U the uh Amendment
2336 uh down on line 28 it's talking
about and it seems like the uh com the
committee here was their intent was to
have a non-transferable license and it
sounds like one of the loopholes is the
sell of uh uh a majority shares in these
company which then allows another one
and my question does if a a hedge fund
or a larger Corporation buys it as a
subsidiary company would they still
remain as a licensee while a larger
Corporation would control the
subsidiary
thank
yes followup followup so would it be
advisable under those 28 if the intent
of the committee is to restrain the
transfer of these licenses to maybe add
a little more in depth verbiage to that
to to control it or do do these
loopholes or do you want to continue
with the loopholes that's up to the
committee thank
you do you have an opinion on that
thought I'm sorry I just confirming my
colleague go I I can address that so as
director McIntyre said it was our
initial assessment that the licenses
were not transferable at all um and
ultimately the Attorney General's office
opined that um the transfer of interests
in the entity would um would be
permissible under the statute as written
there is language in the horse racing
statute um which talks about the um
transfer of 50% or more which is more
specific and my understanding from the
Attorney General's office is that if
that language had been imported into the
historic hor racing bill that it would
have uh placed more restrictions on the
uh on that loophole uh that director
maryre had
identified follow up thank you Mr
chairman now that would cover the stock
purchase portion of it but what happens
if they're bought as a subsidiary of a
larger Corporation has that been
addressed that has not been addressed
specifically um I would have to take a
look at the specific language or the
specific transaction I do want to make
one clarification to we still review
suitability on any ownership transfers
um even if it's within if if it's the
permissible transfer that you're talking
about we would still review the the uh
uh individuals or corporations that are
purchasing that um but with respect to
your specific question um I would have
to get uh get an opinion from the
Attorney General's office on
that representative
Aly thank you uh what is
the do we have any ability to uh go back
fix the language and require that no uh
owner or including of the shares on is
Casino it would it would be difficult to
opine on the legality of it I would
think on a going forward basis um
certainly that would be permissible uh
as retro retroactively I think that
would be difficult to do
and and also I certainly when I was in
Massachusetts one of our sister agencies
where I worked was The Liquor Commission
and there was a law that said only you
could only own three liquor stores and
those with large families owned
more so I would suggest that
they as we are on track to on have an
completely uncontrollable by anybody in
this state on single or double
owners of all of the the casino gambling
in this state but I I did want to
suggest if we're going to have a public
to suspend conversation on at this point
and move to the next as soon well as
soon as you finish that's exactly what I
was going to say because we're going Mr
chairman if I could obviously you were a
member of the commission as well the
study commission and if I could I would
happily provide the same presentation we
gave this week to the members of the
commission as well as updated numbers in
terms of Revenue and the like and also
the same information we're going to
provide to the commission as Senator
Lang said we would provide as well in
advance so that they would have areas to
question us on specifically versus right
that that would that's a good idea I
think um getting an advance is good so
that people can review it and hopefully
move through it and ask uh questions
more appropriately representative
leapley I have a quick question I hope
um and it's about the amendment that we
just received um it says no charitable
organization shall receive less than 35%
of the gross revenues from any games of
chance uh minus any prizes paid so any
games of chance including HHR no
no uh representative thank you for the
question uh games of chance has a
specific meaning within the law and that
doesn't include store for racing okay
and does this amendment um make any
statement about Revenue generation for
the
state yeah I don't think it makes any
changes no okay thank
you thank you thank you very
much all right I'm going to close the
sp12 we'll now open open the work
sp190 any comments on uh sp190 um yes
Senator
Lang thank you members of the committee
so um this bill basically creates a tax
for online what's called Advanced
deposit wagering
another one you'll get in your primer
possibly um but it basically is that in
horse racing um you used to call it you
could call in to a racetrack and place
your bet people don't call in anymore
they use an application on their phone
and this modernize it this is a request
from Lottery and from um the AG's office
to modernize statute to bring it in so
that those apps are considered within
the terms of ADW Advanced deposit
wagering the one ask I would have is if
you pass this is to amend didn't and dro
the taxx rate um we currently have a tax
rate for in place so people like the
brook um currently pay um this this tax
um and so rather than create two
separate tax rates um so on this side of
the aisle or the Republican side of the
AIS argue that you're not creating a new
tax you're just conforming a tax with
with the industry and on the left side
of the aisle you're just going to create
new Revenue um that'll be available for
uh education uh spending um which where
the revenue goes from the state so I'd
ask you to drop the tax to 1.25 which
creates a consistent tax rate whether
you're an inperson or an online gaming
it representative Aly thank you I don't
see the tax rate in here I I don't have
a copy of the bill so not
sure line 12 I think they just said page
two line 12 oh thank you one so it's
1.25 so uh yeah change it move it down
to 1.25 which would be consistent with
existing law for inperson gaming
operators Charlie is that right yeah
that's
right representative
Ames yeah I'm a little confused as to
what um charitable game uh games of
chance would
be
subject so this isn't games of chance
this is strictly simoc cast horse racing
strictly simcast
it's a well I should say sim cast I
think it also covers bround so it also
covers the two locations we have that
are licens so as you know greyhound
racing we've outlawed New Hampshire we
don't do and we restricted the licenses
and grandfathered in and there's only
two facilities left that can do no two
there's Brooke and Belmont are the two
facilities that can do simoc cast racing
because they've had it right now
currently only the brook does it um and
so this would again apply to that simoc
cast horse racing Churchill you know
watching uh the Kentucky Derby and be
able to bet on the Kentucky Derby
because it's outside of the provisions
gaming representative
duet thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um would you be
surprised if I told you there are
Outlets that have been taking these
types of bets for over two decades at at
this time not be taking them at this
very moment but have been taking these
bets I understand there have been
organizations that have been doing that
and the point of this law is to bring
bring give the Attorney General
something to enforce because the again
the issue from the attorney general my
understanding was it's a gray area
they're not sure whether it's loud or
not allow and this just clarifies the
law and makes it easier represent my La
you're killing me you're your your light
is on on the other
side so you're killing not I just want
you to kill your battery that's all
um so again this was a clarification
request this was a housekeeping bill
that it it's it was happening in New
Hampshire there was a question whether
whether it was legal not legal could
they pursue them not pursue them and so
the point of this this bill was to
clarify that law and to say yes in fact
it is legal and yes you are in fact
subject to the tax and to make it
absolutely
clear follow up with all respect I I
disagree with this being a housekeeping
issue what I believe
and if we if we wanted to as an entity
take bets on horse racing that does that
mean I can take a bet on horse racing no
we we have Statute in place and what I
can tell you is I've met with the
attorney general I've brought my
concerns forward I believe some of these
entities that have been taking these
bets who have been um bonusing these
bets so they so people would bet with a
platform rather than going to at the
time Rockingham Park seabook Park and in
my best estimation and it's and it's
kind of kid from Lawrence math in excess
of tens and tens of millions of dollars
in Revenue that this state is
owed and it's my opinion that the
Attorney General needs to do a dig into
this that we don't sweep this under the
rug as a
committee and that we we send this
packing when we exec this bill because I
believe there's some some issues that
need to be addressed at the doj and need
to be addressed directly specific to
this particular piece of legislation so
if I may Mr chair respond so again
pursuant to our constitution we can't
make a retrospective law so we can't go
back in time and you know as that old
saying when's the best time to plant a
tree it was 10 years ago we chose not to
do that we didn't imp we didn't do do
that so now we draw a line in the sand
and say this is the issue whether or not
someone was not complying with the law
10 years ago was completely up to the
attorney general irrespective of this
law being passed so if someone vied the
law a year ago they could still go after
them for violating a law a year ago that
doesn't mean this bill is invalid um so
I guess I just say that again my my
point is I didn't plant the tree 10
years ago so I'm planting the tree now
just to do that housekeeping
clarification and make it absolutely
you
all right I am going to um if there's no
other questions I'm going to end the
sp190 okay
now what I'd like to do is um have a
caucus uh next is is the exec exing
these bills uh we already know that
we cannot exec uh sp12 because we have
um an amendment that we would uh have
public hearing on and we'll do that at
our next meeting so uh the other three
bills um we possibly can exec so I want
to have a uh Republican caucus and I
think uh Susan Aly would like a u
Democratic caucus so it's uh
11:25 um let's try to be back here at um
we need
15 um we probably need 20
uh let's be back here at quarter of
sharp because we don't want to um we if
we can get this all done and uh not go
to lunch and come back I'm sure you all
would like that so let's be uh prompt
and be back here at quarter of 12 so
next
e
right uh the time being five of 12 now
started I'm going to open the U exec
hp450
representative shamber would you like to
make a motion thank you Mr chairman i'
would like to make a motion to approve
House Bill 450 relative to removing the
net operating loss deduction limit on
taxable income under the business
profits
tax I'd like to second
that okay any
discussion uh the the only discussion
that I think that we had
was in
did you want to move an
amendment I'm sorry i' like to
move the amendment
[Music]
two 2023
d227
seconded and would you like to speak to
your motion just very quickly uh what
this amendment does it removes the 80%
limit on net operating loss and moves it
back to the
original uh
100% and it keeps in place the
10-year uh limiting period and uh the
million thank you and um I I'd also just
like to mention that I am as the author
of the other three amendments I am with
drawing um Amendment
2273 H 2274 H and
2290h so we are only um looking at
2272 any other comment uh representative
yes just uh as an observation Amendment
2272 H follows the same purpose as the
underlying Bill uh regarding the 80%
limit being restored to 100% where it
was was prior to
2018 but it also addresses the dr's uh
concern uh that we do not limit it
purely to C corporations and that's
clarified in the amendment thank you
yeah that's clarify lines 28 and 29 yes
else all right seeing none the clerk
will
take yes Mr chair on the amendment uh
this is a a vote on Amendment 2272 H for
450 FN I'll ask uh chairman Jin inan how
he votes
yes chair representative erery yes
representative duet yes representative
spillsbury yes representative PL votes
yes representative
Boger yes representative sodi yes
representative ores yes representative
rosi yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative shanberg yes
representative Brian yes representative
Bolton yes representative Elber
yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith is not here correct
Jeffrey Smith is not here okay and
representative Boyd
yes so that's 19 to zero one not
voting
uh the vote being 19 to zero is there
any um can we put it on consent or do we
have any objections to that we have to
do it again I'm sorry right let's do the
you all right so the amendment uh being
passed and the um the bill itself
um do we have any uh comment on the bill
itself of course which is actually the
amendment because it's been replaced in
fa so I'm going assume there's no
questions and the clerk will take the
role I have to take the role even though
outcome representative janigian yes
representative Valery yes representative
duet yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative bogert yes representative
sodi yes representative ORS yes
representative rord yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes representative shamber yes
representative o'ban yes representative
Bolton
yes representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes and
representative uh Boyd
yes did I miss
somebody 4 5
six yeah I did 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 19
to
zero one not voting thank you the the
vote being 19 to zero now does anyone
have any objections to the consent
calendar yes did you have a yeah
representative Aly I this does um take a
little bit of money away so I think that
under okay you could check on we can we
that okay all right we'll we'll check on
that all right uh we will close the exec
on
hp450 we're going to open the exec
session on HP
494 recognize representative all me
thank you on I'd like to move on ought
to pass on HB 494
second I'll second that Mr chairman who
shamberg and um then move on uh
the amendment
hb2 HB
494 number
H all right do we have a
chairman yes on the amendment on
clarifies the situation of
a
key fund inside of the department in
agriculture which is meant to deal with
um Agricultural Product testing and
registration
testing uh and field
inspection issues um a lot of this is
not going on at this point because of
on the dedicated fund that is now called
the Agricultural Product and scale
testing fund
on has not done scale testing for quite
a long time and it also is not doing a
lot of the work that needs to be done to
to uh test and guarantee the contents of
pet food and cans the contents of animal
feed the contents of fertilizers and
liming and other soil
amendments on which is a major part of
the work of a normal Department of
Agriculture um it also has a
uh a large reserve of
1.25 million at this point you take
away um the money that was spent out of
it last year for
animal um datab
base but that money would
disappear fairly quickly if they were
not added to it on the
two small funds in here the um in
on 430
and and
[Music]
four uh
431 uh 6 I believe it is I've got to
check on those um they add up to
considerably less than a million dollars
but adding them to um this new newly
named fund agricultural products Reg
regulatory fund on will
allow um the fund to
continue uh to match expenditures with
um with
revenues and they were part of the
original um bill which was to create a
totally new
fund uh to do what was supposed to be
done in this fund and
the the other thing that this does is to
write into law for the first time the
actual purpose of this
Fund in addition to renaming it to
reflect that
purpose so it
um it simplifies things and it
challenges the Department of Agriculture
to start um building up the databases
they need to free up their staff to
work in the fields and in the um uh
manufacturing industry food
manufacturing Industries to um do the
inspection and supervision and testing
that they should be doing so that's
thank you any
other
comments all right seeing none can can I
just clarify yes so representative Aly
am I understanding it correctly we're
not creating a new fund we're relabeling
and
explaining an existing fund exactly but
we're also broadening it by directing
three additional sources of revenue that
previously have gone to the general fund
will now be added to that pot it's two
um and I've got to oh here it is on
section two and section
43142 um to move that money in and both
of these are for are concerning uh
fertilizer and soil amendments um and
4316 to read as follows that they're
going to deposit that into there uh at
this point those are both going to the
general fund but they are
collected from uh
companies on I believe it's all
companies that are actually um doing
creating fertilizer and creating uh soil
amendments
okay and the fees is under four as well
right and and there the the I need to to
look it up again but in the dedicated
fund book they they've been
bring uh well they aren't in the
dedicated fund book but it was
in in one of our I think here it's in
the original fiscal note um they bring
in a total each year of$
385,000
so they are not much of a loss to the
general fund and they are the tonnage
registration program for soil and plant
uh uh I I'll look them up and the
fertilizer registration program and the
lyming registration program there are
three of them two of them must be in the
clear all right uh representative ORS so
just so I understand the two new funds
are one's for the database money's going
to the database no the database was uh
settled last year uh the commissioner
got a bill through to take
250,000 out of this fund that we are
renaming uh
to be used in creating the uh
dog uh
registration uh database once they've
got that database up it's a template for
the rest of the department to start um
to create databases for parzer and lming
to create a database over in pest
control and and I personally expect that
they will
um
use parts of that million 25 that's left
uh in end of year balance each year to
create those databases so that they can
modernize the
department very good thank you it
sounded the the gentleman that was
talking with us before is the head of
the regulatory Bureau which is the one
that is responsible for all of
this thank
you all right seeing uh no more
questions uh the clerk will take the
role on Amendment
2342 thank you Mr
chair uh chairman J janigian yes
representative erery yes representative
duet yes representative spillsbury yes
representative plvs yes representative
Boger yes representative sodi yes
representative ORS yes representative
rord yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative o Brian yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
and representative Boyd yes 190 one not
voting
okay um the amendment uh passes um
now again this amendment is our place
all so I'm assuming no one else uh has
any U comments so the clerk will take
the role Yes again I have to even though
I know the outcome um you're pretty
smart represent janigian chairman J
again yes representative oler yes
representative duet yes represent
spillsbury yes representative vot yes PL
votes yes representative Boger yes
representative sod yes representative
ores yes representative rord yes
representative Aly yes representative
Ames yes representative Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
and representative Boyd yes
190 one not voting all right the vote
being 190 any objections to consent yes
representative Aly turn your microphone
on could you check with the clerk about
whether 3 385,000
is enough that it needs to be on the
regular
calendar all right
allow would it is it required to be on
the regular calendar so you're asking is
there a threshold by which if we go over
then yeah 285,000 yeah well we know know
the other one has we have an undefinable
actually fiscal note on the other one we
don't know how much it could cost but on
this one isn't the cost where it's from
the general fund it's from the general
fund
yes okay so I just maybe I should have
tried to check with the clerk beforehand
but I'm not sure and representative Aly
will write the committee
report you'll you'll write the committee
right okay we'll close the exec session
494 as far as sb112
goes uh we established earlier during
our work session that we need to do
public hearing so we will not exec sp12
at this time um at our next meeting
which uh we're planning on being our
last for this year we'll have a public
hearing and then we'll
sp12 any question yes representative
Ames just uh I I expect to um do an
amendment to 112 also okay that will uh
be narrow and specifically focused on
the
moratorium issue and the license
transfer issue that we
discussed um and uh I guess it's
important to know what our what the
deadline is because you need to have
that Amendment uh when we go to that um
when when are you can I ask when we
might be meeting um it it's looking like
we're probably going to meet um three
weeks from now on November 9th okay yeah
that would be fine from I'm sure yeah
and that would be our that would be our
last meeting so we'll need to finish uh
all
business all right any other any other
comments before I move on to
sp190 okay uh seeing none I will open
sp190 and um representative ducet would
you like to make a motion thank you Mr
sp190 do we have a
second
second all right would you like to speak
to your
motion I think I've spoken to it
okay any representative
Aly thank you um I understand that uh
Senator Lang is planning on putting in
another bill about this in
January so we would have a second
chance to discuss
this so we would have a second chance to
discuss
this
right well then I would suggest um we
have a number of questions about it
because we don't really understand
on who is betting
where uh I I was under the impression
that it it
this is includes any New Hampshire
person who is establishing a bit with
any of the three companies that had been
doing this and now two of them are still
doing it but they don't it doesn't have
brook
all
right so I think that that helps us a
little but we um we really wanted to see
interim study or something similar on
this
bill I don't know if anyone else wants
to speak who else
um you want to speak to it FR yeah just
just to be clear I think that there's
some substantial issues with this
legislation uh going forward and we need
to dig deeper than studying it I think
we need to set send this out itl and we
can come back and look at another piece
of legislation again the Kick the Can
down the road approach we need to stop
doing that this this needs to be
addressed it's a true issue it's my
belief that the state has
owed large revenues by some of these
folks that have been taking these types
of bets and the AG of the State of New
Hampshire needs to address this directly
and I think the best course of action is
legislation yes representative Aly thank
you this is the first time I've heard in
this room specified by anybody well that
I've heard it all on what issue might be
involved so you're talking about the
past bets that people were doing under
the federal law and that are still going
going on under the federal law by two
companies that we should be able to
recoup money
from is that what you're saying
representative I'm not an attorney but
what I can tell you is this I know for
decades a certain entity was taking bets
on simal cast racing and they were not
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
to take bets on simulcast racing hard
stop we lost Revenue in in the
neighborhood of what whatever 1
uh
25% of those millions and tens of
millions of dollars were and I believe
it's the the process that the AG should
pursue that um I've met with the AG uh
it's going to be his decision at at the
end of the day but I plan on being a
loud proponent to pursue this we are
owed substantial Revenue as a state
we're here to talk about Revenue in my
piece representative ORS thank you Mr
chairman uh my my thoughts are similar
to uh representative Duets just in that
if we are owed a large chunk of Revenue
due to slight of hand where somebody
wasn't playing
fair if we cannot keep them out of
future business I I would think uh we
should see this through and see if there
is a chance to collect these revenues if
they are as substantial as a
representative do set seems to think
they
are representative
Aly yes I'm trying to understand as I as
I understand it we have a situation
where we've got uh three companies which
have been taking bets under the federal
law uh without a New Hampshire
law and those three companies realized
somehow last year that they were
supposed to be under the New Hampshire
law and two of them have just continued
taking
bets and the third one Churchill Downs
has suspended taking bets until this
gets worked
out
and the effect
of not passing this now or at least uh
having a chance to look at it next year
would be that for two more years this
situation would continue those two other
companies will be taking bets from New
Hampshire and the one unless the
Attorney General is a wizard and gets
through things a lot quicker than they
usually do uh the other one Churchill
Downs would continue to be
suspended and it suspended
itself representative
duet and not not to name specific
vendors or what have you but I I would
uh I would offer that it's been a lot
longer than the last year that they knew
this was going on and one would have to
ask themselves why would you stop doing
something that you've been doing for
decades because a piece of legislation
was submitted okay I think it Ling this
puts the fire to the feet of the AG's
office and the doj's office to get
something done for the state so I'm not
sending a muted message to the industry
what I'm saying is this we're
owed it's our attorneys General's job to
pursue that and it needs to be pursued
I've known about it for a number of
years and it keeps getting SW swept away
and all of a sudden this legislation
session yes representative
Southworth uh thank you um would this
also be able to be address through the
commission not at all I don't mean um
the owing the money I mean clarifying uh
some of the items in uh the bill it's
not charitable it's not okay just wanted
to make sure about
that representative PL yes I'm no
attorney but if we were to pass this
legislation then the Attorney General
pursued it in court the courts could say
well you got law now so it's moved uh
and so we could lose that
Revenue representative Aly it does seem
to me that we've only got uh one of
we've only stopped because it stopped
itself one of the three
on groups that is um benefiting by
not on paying attention to the New
Hampshire law and is the attorney
general going to in response to this
two represent I may
I I can't speak for the attorney General
I've met with the attorney general
brought this issue the clock is ticking
um others have brought this to his
attention and I think a clear statement
from this committee to the attorney
clearer representative ORS uh thank you
Mr chairman so I'm just wondering if uh
anybody's gotten any feedback maybe
Senator Lang even uh as to whether or
not the Attorney General plans to do
anything take action
or let's uh let's keep the discussion in
the committee um representative ducet
has been talking to the Attorney
else yes is there a way to uh open up a
discussion Andor negotiations with these
other two and maybe the one that has
suspended their own activity and see if
pursuing that's yeah that's up to the AG
to to do
that okay anything
else all right the clerk will take the
role thank you Mr chair and I'll start
with chairman J
janigian for itl on SP sp19 FN yes
representative Valery yes representative
duet yes representative spsb yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Boger yes represent sodi
yes representative ORS yes
representative Rochford yes
representative Aly no representative
Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes Representative
shamberg
no representative O'Brien
no representative Bolton no
representative
elberger
yes representative
leapley yes repes representative uh Boyd
voting okay the vote being 15 to4 the
itl
passes and representative du set you'll
do the the
blurb okay
um so our next order of business what's
that I guess I will do a
okay all right representative uh Aly
will do a minority
blurb all right next on the agenda is to
schedule our next and final
meeting one more question yeah represent
you going to be arguing interim
study yes if I'm allowed to I can't
remember whether the clerk allows that
or not all right but that's what I'm
you okay so as I said previously our
final our final
meeting that we need to schedule which
um I'm planning on November 9th Thursday
November 9th at that meeting we
will have a work session and exec hp11
worldwide combined reporting of which um
representative spillsbury uh by then
will have had the final two meetings and
and a decision uh there um HP 192
relative the uh interest and dividence
tax HP 569 relative to the State
education property tax and I think
representative Ames you are still
waiting for a judgment um from the court
which we still are wait still waiting
for um and then
um actually not last because we'll
probably do this one first but uh s SP
112 we'll have the public hearing first
uh we'll schedule public hearing on that
we will EXA EXA that bill that being our
last meeting on the 9th we need to exec
everything left which would be those
four bills um so that will be November
9th uh time
um probably 9:30 again so we make sure
that uh we can get through this and not
have to go to lunch and come back um so
our next meeting will be
questions all right thank you
everyone
right